where exactly is wakanda this
technologically advanced fictional
country is located right here or over
here wait no over here okay there's some
level of disagreement on where it is on
a map but it's depicted as being
somewhere in East Africa so where
exactly is wakanda located and why was
this specific Place chosen
[Music]
it's not actually a real country there
are differing records of where wakanda
is located on a map but all of these
records place it somewhere in East
Africa showcased in the Marvel films
Black Panther and wakanda forever this
country is recognized as the most
technologically advanced nation in the
world with invisibility and shielding
capabilities around the entire country
to keep it isolated from the rest of the
world the source of wakanda's
technological advancements comes from a
large meteorite made of vibranium that
they call Mena and guy which Powers all
of their Tech and runs their cities this
country is led by a king called the
Black Panther who has superhuman
abilities which he gets from eating
herbs mutated by the vibranium meteorite
as for the country's location some
sources put wakanda north of Tanzania
While others put it directly on top of
Rwanda or on Lake Victoria but the most
popular Source places wakanda at the
Northern end of Lake turkana between
South Sudan Uganda Kenya and Ethiopia
the capital of wakanda berninzana was
built directly on top of the vibrate
meteorite this city featured in Avengers
Infinity war and black panther is
heavily influenced by the presence of
vibranium the biggest reason why this
city and the entire country was formed
and built in this specific location was
because it's just where their sacred
meteorite landed without its powerful
vibranium wakanda would likely be no
different from the rest of the East
African nations at Borders or it might
have never even formed the wakandans
also have a very rich culture and strong
ties to their ancestors who discovered
the vibranium in wakanda there are four
main religious sects the followers of
Bost the panther goddess the followers
of Hanuman the Guerrilla God the
followers of sekhmet the lion goddess
and the followers of Sobek the crocodile
God in the films we mostly see the
followers of Bost and the ruling family
of wakanda and the followers of Hanuman
in the Jabari tribe and their leader
umbaku in wakanda there are three
official languages spoken wakandan
Yoruba and hausa in the films the
wakandan language is simply the South
African Cosa language with a few small
differences the wakandan language is
depicted with a writing system based on
the insibility writing system and it was
created for the film by production
designer Hannah beechler in the comics
wakanda is the foremost military power
on earth mostly because of their
technological prowess from their
vibranium Weaponry in order to ensure
peace and stability in wakanda the Black
Panther picked the Dora milaje or adored
ones from rival tribes to serve as his
personal guard which we've seen as
active combatants in MCU wakanda also
has its own intelligence system known as
the encharo Selema a spy Network that
works across the globe to maintain the
nation's secrecy it was considered as
good as the Mossad and certainly better
than the CIA and MI6 it's these kinds of
advantages which makes wakanda such an
interesting place to study but none of
it would be possible if it weren't for
the vibranium meteorite that landed here
or here or over here
okay that's it check out the video on
your screen for some more of my content
don't forget to like And subscribe and
thanks for watching Rocket Riley
[Music]